[Music]
time now for the second installment of
our new series defending the first where
we expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free expression and free
thought radio talk show hosts and daily
wire editor-in-chief ben shapiro has
emerged as one of the top defenders of
free speech particularly on campus in a
series of speeches over the last few
years Shapiro has debunked sacred cows
like safe spaces microaggressions and
the quest for well multiculturalism and
diversity and not without risks to his
own personal safety you will and there
it is gang guess what you know what
they're not going to stop us
[Applause]
if I attempt to enter that hall right
there and sit down just to listen to
somebody speak or if I attempt to ask a
questions or to engage in free speech
you will have me arrested disappoint the
tolerant ones joining us now ben shapiro
himself but we thought of immediately
when we launched this series Ben you
know you don't look too threatening yeah
you're kind of a guy with some
interesting ideas and thought-provoking
conversations and you freaked them all
out got the head gear on it cut the riot
police out it is funny because it's so
pathetic but it's also very dangerous
because you do have the guts to go on
college campuses but there are a lot of
conservatives I know who are invited to
speak you know what they say and I have
better things to do with my time and in
a way you can't blame them but that is
its self chilling free speech no no
question the hecklers veto that so many
universities are now using to shut down
free speech on college campuses by
saying the left is gonna get violence
it's pretty astonishing and listen I
don't blame conservatives who don't want
to take their life in their hands by
going on some of these campuses now I
don't want to pretend this is happening
at every campus but it is happening to a
lot of conservatives I mean I'm talking
about not even just conservatives I'm
talking about people who range from
Jordan Peterson to Jason Riley to
Heather McDonald to charles murray now
there's there's a wide variety of
conservatives who are being really
rioted against in some cases on campus
and the administration has in some cases
really not done enough to to prevent
that from happening and when they do
attempt to stop the rise from happening
the way they typically do it is by
bringing a lot of cops on the campus and
then by suggesting that we have to
restrict the number of people who can
actually attend the lecture so they
actually end up restricting free speech
even when they're attempting to protect
it in some cases yeah so again irony the
Free Speech Movement and all started at
Berkeley and Berkeley as is that Center
you know ground cent got the ground zero
of the anti free speech movement in the
United States today in the last couple
of days an interesting development been
that fits with our series at Penn State
the Penn State student power Network
along with other students and community
members gathered outside old Maine on
Monday to present a list of demands to
President Barron I love it when they
have a list of demands
these demands included denouncing and
defunding hate groups on campus I think
to myself oh my god are the Nazis I mean
who's on campus is you know s Communist
Party know its groups with
anti-immigrant rhetoric I don't mean I
guess that's someone who's in favor of
enforcing the border wait what does that
man I mean everything has been deemed
hate speech on campus up to an including
there's point during the election cycle
when people were barred on certain
campuses from writing president Trump's
a name when he was a candidate because
this made people feel bad that some
people actually supported Trump as a
candidate so the I can only imagine that
anti-immigrant rhetoric would be things
like let's enforce our border or let's
deport some illegal immigrants but that
that's not a shock again Penn State is
one of the campuses that I visited and
there was a near riot when I was at Penn
State so it's I'm sure that some of the
people who are protesting against the
the conservatives on campus and it was
some conservative groups who they were
protesting now were some of the same
people who a couple of years ago you
know they tried to break through the
doors where I was speaking to disrupt
the lecture that I was giving what's
amazing about all of us is that it is
perfectly easy to have a nice event
where people come and listen to me or
listen to any of the other people I
mentioned and all of us are willing to
have q and A's all of us are willing to
have discussions we had one last night
over at Pepperdine where a lot of the
student groups who are on the Left I'm
talking about the same sort of minority
student groups you're hearing about a
Penn State decided that instead of
boycotting they would show up and ask
questions and we had a perfectly nice
conversation but unfortunately there is
a part of the left as distinguished from
I think liberals at large there's
there's a big part of the left and it's
growing that says that it is incumbent
to protect the campus from ideas that
are dissenting and everyone who descends
must be thrown off well and and the
reason that they want a stifle speech is
because your speech actually grows
conservatism it spreads the ideology and
it draws people in they have no ideas
they're out of ideas they're out of
solutions they're into demonization and
you know you go to college campuses you
could be going to corporations and
speaking but you go to college campuses
and I think the groups that are trying
to make your life miserable or going
after charlie Kirk and Turning Point USA
go go through the list of who's behind
effort to really tamp down on free
speech we know some of the big funded
groups by George Soros but go through
that briefly for us I mean that there's
certainly a lot of student groups that
coordinated say that a lot of the groups
that are associated with the Women's
March are very much associated with this
movement a lot of the groups that were
originally associated with black lives
matter were very active in this campus
movement obviously an Tifa was the the
far edge wing of this movement that was
actually promoting violence at a lot of
these speeches but the the generalized
attempt to shut down speeches by
pressuring administrations that's a lot
of student groups that have been on
campus since the time that I was on
college campuses as a student myself and
they continue to push for the idea these
campuses should be conservative free and
should be complete safe spaces for
people on the left not only because they
think that conservatives are going to
convince a lot of people but also
because they actually just think
conservatives are evil I think that it's
they really think that people like me
are there to do them harm and when I
show up and it turns out that I'm a
relatively non-threatening character and
I've never really beaten anyone up in my
life for several reasons that you can
imagine then you know that's the impact
yeah well again you don't look too
threatening but ideas are threatening to
these people
then thanks so much